june shows coming up hollywood june 4th
i'm at the troubadour it's going to be a
really cool show june 24th i'm in des
moines iowa one night only june 25th
headed to omaha nebraska one night only
and back at brea california
june 30th one night only as well get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media i want to thank you guys i
want to thank you for continuing to
support this channel and this show and
also want to thank everyone that's come
out to see me on tour so far all right
night pants nation tour is on its way
um get tickets for all shows at
ryansickler.com
des moines i will be there june 24th one
night only in omaha june 25th one night
only alright make sure you subscribe to
the youtube if you gotta have more
honeydew then you gotta hear the patreon
i am telling you that community is
growing every month and not one time if
we had less people once you hear it
you're in all right it's the honeydew
with y'all and i'm highlighting the low
lights with y'all and i promise y'all
got some [ __ ] lowlights out there and
we have listen we have hundreds of
emails
still we could do this show for years
i'm telling you submit because we're
looking for the best stuff out there all
right submit your story if you have one
that has to be heard honeydewpodcast
gmail.com all right you don't need to be
a patreon to do the show all right but
if you want to be a patreon it's five
bucks a month if you sign up for a year
you get over a month free all right and
you're getting the honeydew a day early
ad free at no additional cost that's it
there's no tears no any of that stuff
it's five bucks and do yourself a favor
sign up for a year that's for like four
bucks or something like that all right
now you guys know what we do over here
we highlight the low lights these are
the stories behind the storytellers
today very excited to have here first
time on the do ladies and gentlemen
please welcome paulie shore welcome to
the honeydew paulie i don't know if i'm
gonna do this now i just realized what
this [ __ ] podcast is so i'm supposed
to talk about my low lows
yeah in a highway oh
man you ready to get up about your lows
on the mic real good
all right well before we get into what
we're gonna talk about today plug
everything and anything you would like
um okay i'm in the new pinocchio movie i
played the voice of pinocchio that just
came out with lion's gate
and which was cool so i'm in that and
then also a new animated film called my
sweet monster and i play the uh the
villain in that and then i have a
one-man show about my childhood called
stick with the dancing so we want to
promote that
and then um all my stuff online i'm
really excited about you know all this
stuff on youtube i've abandoned vegas
that i [ __ ] with and
um
i don't know wise guys downtown arts
district you know it's a club that i
helped kind of open for keith um from
utah that's doing really well and it's a
great it's a great [ __ ] room for the
comics you know so every comic that
plays there really and tony loved it and
and annie loved it and and everyone josh
wolfe is there and um so that's that
and then what else what other stuff i
don't know you know i'm back and forth
from here in vegas and then the uh the
comments are 50th anniversary very
respect my parents my dad started it
then my mom ran it and um and now my
brothers are running it so
so look let's let's just go there
because let's start at the beginning
because you said you have a one-man show
about your childhood yeah
so i mean if you're doing a one-man show
you obviously have a lot to say about it
but i'm gonna say this to you before we
begin anything i want to say
like i watched your rogan interview i
watched a lot of your [ __ ] dude i go
back i think we're probably close
similar in age i'm 49 54 yeah there you
go so
i remember all these tv kids that's
right i have a daughter and a step son
you're a seven and eighteen beautiful
he's about to see i don't have a i don't
have a baby none no that's a holder i
didn't have an abortion once
but i didn't put that on the pamphlet
for you guys to talk about
you guys
you guys can talk about you guys can
talk about that [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
gnarly dude
you want to talk about it i guess but
we'll go wherever you want to go all
right we'll come back to children but
i want to give you your credit because
going back to mtv and then being a movie
star the a lady i always talk about her
sam miss sandy she was my mom growing up
my mom who was my mom left the family
her name's sandy patterson okay and
her daughter was like a sister to me her
son shannon and we're still all very
very very tight and this is back in
baltimore mm-hmm copy and um
her daughter was killed in a car
accident and it just brought us all
together in a weird sad way as well 16.
and your movie son-in-law comes out and
she was just going through it and i'm as
a bunch of us kids are staying at her
house for a little while and stuff and
um i'm in the basement and i'm watching
son-in-law and she comes down and she
sits there and she's like what are you
watching this is paulie shore son-in-law
and i'm telling you she sat and watched
the whole movie
it became this little connection for us
and when i i called her right away when
you were official i called her i was
like guess who's coming on the podcast
so she's all stoked what's her name
sandy patterson sandy what's up it's
paulie shore um i know that you've
probably been through some crazy [ __ ]
but the good thing is we all have
and we're all going through crazy [ __ ]
so i love you and thank you for liking
my movie son-in-law [ __ ] yeah check out
pinocchio bro
she's got a yeah
there you there you go so um thank you
yeah you know i get that
you know it's amazing because i still
pinch myself you know i still pinch
myself i go on tour and
and i pinch myself when people come up
and they're crying and they say oh this
movie saved me and my friend was dying
of cancer and my dad watched this movie
and and he died right after he saw it
and i'm just kidding
and he stopped by aldrin he's like that
was the last thing he died he killed
himself
um no it's interesting because because
uh the movies came out and i was so
popular at the time
that you know when you're spinning and
you're so popular you're gonna it's
gonna crash at some point you can't
sustain you know i was doing i was doing
all this forever yeah yeah i was doing
all this [ __ ] but the good part is is
whether the critics like the movies or
not
20 30 years later they're actually more
strong now
than they were back then i know this
because i sell tickets you know on the
road
you know what i mean
and i don't sell tickets i don't sell
tickets
because of my netflix special i don't
sell tickets because of my youtube
channel i sell tickets because you know
my films and then you know they start to
see my other stuff but
that's how special those movies were
that i did and it just makes me feel
really good that i was able to to do
those films and make people feel really
good you know and it's beautiful you
know it's a beautiful thing and so is
the fact that you're alive yeah you know
what i'm saying you're 54 yes and in
this business yeah especially
you see so many people come and
literally go if you're fortunate enough
to still be around i'm doing i'm doing
the beach show you do the honeydew i got
the beets
the beet show it's the honeydew and meat
the beets the beets meet the honeydew
and then the ginger no i just mix that
[ __ ] up no i just i live in vegas so
it's like there's not a lot of juice out
there so i come here to la and i go to
the juicery on santa monica on santa
monica boulevard where they just have
all the juices just drink these juices
so yeah i like to drink the juices mix
it up
so let's go back to the beginning with
the comedy store and your mom and i i
don't know how sick you are of talking
about it but i want to know because i
want to know your point of view you're
talking about this one-man show from
your childhood talk to me about it what
where does the one-man show begin the
one-man show there's not a lot of
sadness in it it's what i'll do there's
yeah there's sadness
there's sad it's mostly like how because
a lot of people the people that do know
me they know me from the mtv and the
movies and and and and the stand up and
all that [ __ ] and the people that don't
know me they don't know that my mom and
my dad started the store and that i grew
up around there so
the one man show is basically saying yo
you guys know this [ __ ] but what you
don't know is this [ __ ] so it's
basically me kind of unveiling all the
questions that everyone wants to know
what was it like having richard pryor
there what was it like robin
what was your first time you meet
kennison yeah what's your first memory
of all of it that's what i want to start
at the beginning like what do you first
remember how old are you
remember at the comedy store it was just
rock and roll you know my mom was cool
my dad was cool when they first started
me and my brothers would [ __ ] run
around my sister was wild as [ __ ] you
know my sister a lot of people don't
know that i had a sister she passed away
um about three years ago which was
[ __ ] up yeah sandy and she was so
special
you know um
and she was wild and she dropped acid
and and she used to go out the guy named
filthy mcnasty um years ago uh the viper
room the viper room i remember the viper
room yeah but years before that was
filthy mcnasty's oh that's what it was
and so he used to pick her up in his
[ __ ] hearse with flames on it and
this was like his [ __ ] his car is is
you know his uh and he would honk the
horn and it would sound like an ice
cream truck you know like
not scream sandy filthy's here you know
what i mean and this was my life and my
parents divorced when i was three so my
mom was busy at the store my dad was on
the road with elvis and and doing
whatever he was elvis
yeah my dad opened for elvis for 10
years yeah no [ __ ] i see i didn't know
that yeah and my dad did you ever meet
elvis you did you did yeah yeah yeah
smell my finger here's the king the game
from the [ __ ] king man
[Applause]
and uh
[Music]
no so i my dad also remarried to a woman
named stephanie stephanie was related to
melissa gilbert
so for a short time i was related to
melissa gilbert so as a kid i would
little house on the prairie yeah a
little house on the prairie as a kid my
dad would take me to set a little house
on the prairie really yeah where was
that
i think it was at radisson studio or
some [ __ ] back in the day when they used
to have sets and stuff like that
but um but yeah it was um and how old
are you when you're this comedy store
stuff i was four
four years old
four in there well my parents opened it
in 72 so um i was four yeah i was four
and then um i'm the youngest of four as
well so i have peter and then there's
sandy and then scott
so and it's weird because they're all
from the same mom and same dad yet me
and scott my oldest brother are 15 years
apart but yeah
my parents didn't like each other which
is [ __ ] weird because they didn't
like each other yet they kept having
kids
you know what i mean and you don't get
abortions back then you just don't you
know
and um
um
but yeah it was um
you know my mom was cool you know she
was cool you know she loved her
comedians
and but she was also a good mom
she wasn't like she didn't neglect me
she she always made sure the comedians
took care of me like i got a nice email
from lois bromfield who is a very funny
female lesbian comedian that actually
raised me
telling hey you know hey great you know
great for the store and congratulations
and stuff
but yeah she just you know i was like a
hot potato
you know what i mean i was just kind of
giving you know binder to every single
one of them took care of argus you know
dated my mom i mean he was [ __ ]
gnarly dude back in the day argus was
really gnarly
you know like coke drinking like abusive
and you're seeing all this yes
yeah
yeah my mom picked really bad guys you
know but my mom believed in argus
you know what i mean she thought he was
going to be the next but he was you know
he's a cokehead you know and it was sad
to see him but he was like a violent
cockhead you know it was real whatever
you think it was 10 times worse it was
gnarly
yeah it was [ __ ] gnarly
and then you know the k the kenneson and
dice the kenneth cena dice food was a
little little gnarly as well because i
love dice and i love sam and i was kind
of in the middle of that
[ __ ] and uh
you know it was a different time back
then you know now it's like you know you
mind your p's and q's you know wherever
you go and back then you know life was
just like whatever you say you did
and um it's just the way of the world
yeah
how were you when you first tried drugs
i wasn't a druggie never no i mean
around i didn't blow
once in a while but it was always like
once in a while you know it was like the
beverly hills high school prom you know
i went to the
i went to the prom at beverly hills high
school was hilarious because i was a the
uh
the my friend my friend uh peter bill
drove the drove my mom's limo peter bill
is the son of tony bill the director
that did all the [ __ ] i don't know
you have your girl what's your girl's
name kirsten kirsten google cool google
um uh tony bill he's a big director back
in the day like all these so he was his
son was my limo driver for for the prom
and um
and uh in my mom's limo so this is the
limo that all the comedians you know my
mom would the comedians would drive them
out like freddy soto would drive my mom
around it and
and all that stuff and my mom was
hilarious so she like take the limo to
your prom just be just have it home by
tomorrow
so [ __ ]
so we went to the we went to the uh uh
we went to the prom at the at the hilton
in in in beverly hills you know as far
as the um
the uh uh the food part you know that
was the beginning and then there was the
after prom you know the after thing yeah
so the food part everyone was coked out
you know so you got you got all these
beverly hills kids and all these these
these stuffed chickens with pilaf and
rice and no one's eating [ __ ] and
everyone's just like
you know what i mean so that was like a
big deal um it was you know beverly
hills in the 80s it was like you know
that it was you're born and raised west
hollywood born and raised in west
hollywood i mean man there's not many of
you out there yeah like yeah me and josh
richmond that's about it josh richmond
was a really really good friend of mine
when we started together acting he was
best friends with keanu reeves and
and a lot of locals from l.a no josh
richmond um so yeah it was just kind of
us so what was your what what before mtv
what really
you know boosted you up was it just
performing at the store what what
catapulted you and got you in front of
that audience
it was just my determination i mean were
you auditioning was that something you
auditioned for
what happened was is is i always knew i
was going to do stand up so it wasn't
like you know at a young age like little
and i just kind of like was obsessed
with my dad and my mom and the store and
making you know what i mean but i wanted
to live my um my childhood you know i
wanted to surf i wanted to um
i wanted a skateboard i wanted to you
know i was a mod for a while do you know
what a mod is it's basically that [ __ ]
that started in london with the mud
flaps and you know it's like i spoke
like with an english accent for a while
okay you know it's all right mate where
do my [ __ ] mods we are the mods we
are the mods we are we are we are the
mods and we would
do our scooters so i wanted to be a kid
so the beginning of 12th grade is when i
started to take it serious so everything
i did in my life i always took serious
believe it or not a lot of people might
think like oh polish was [ __ ] up but
there was always like kind of a a plan
in place so 18.
no it was no senior in high school 17
the beginning
yeah yeah so that's when i decided i go
i'm gonna [ __ ] start
so um so i started doing stand-up and
and just working everywhere but the
store you know oh really yeah okay yeah
and then argus wrote some jokes from me
angel salazar wrote jokes
um
i think jack perdue who took care of me
he would write some jokes from me ollie
joe prater i don't know just different
comics would help me with my jokes
but i i stayed away from the store
yeah
and then mtv hits and boom
yeah
yeah it was basically um
i was i was uh i was doing a movie
called phantom of the phantom of the
mall in 88
1988
and um
and my manager got a call and they said
mtv has heard about you there was like a
buzz in in the town about me so they
came to see me at the store and um and
that went well and then they i think a
couple months after that they flew me to
spring break for mtv but that didn't go
good i did no i mean how could it i feel
like it was a [ __ ] mess dude i i mean
i pretty much got sent home
it was like because i was nervous and i
didn't i didn't really know where i fit
in and i was just kind of there
um so
so once all that starts then you've all
i've always seen you rolling with
beautiful women when does all that begin
because you you brought up savannah
on your email and i forgot i i forgot
about savannah yeah until you said that
i was like yeah this this woman was one
of the not just the porn star he's one
of the most popular figures at the time
yeah for sure everyone knew who she was
when does all that star for you
it was kind of a whirlwind you know it
was right after the mtv stuff it was
around that time you know it was hot off
of mtv
and then um you know that's kind of like
how it all happened and you met her
where
i met her at the comedy store
um i i was at the uh i was at the porn
awards
and i met this guy uh sean aka edward
edward penis hands
he had a um you know back in the day
they had all that they had like you know
they had a uh what was it it was uh um
you know it was like it was his hands
and every finger had a deal they would
have come all yeah
so i was like i was like dude you're
edward penis hands you know like yeah
man what's up so we switched numbers
back back in the day and then um he came
to the comedy store my mom threw me a uh
i used to do a club there called club
wheeze and it was just like you know
peter bill was there
my friend and different you know my
brothers were there it was just like
different friends we would you know [ __ ]
around at the store like a dj
and stuff and um
and my mom kind of gave me a night and
he brought her to club wiese
and then that night you know we hooked
up and it was pretty awesome i just fell
in love with her yeah you know she was
adorable she was like 21 and i was like
23.
and she was just really cool and funny
she made me laugh and my mom loved her
you know she's just a really cool chick
how long did you date
um
probably like two years oh wow okay yeah
on and off so you really did like her
yeah because we got along you know she's
a nice person she made me laugh
you know so and she was cool so
and then she committed was suicide she
committed suicide what do you know
actually what happened are you
comfortable talking about it yeah um
i put it in the pamphlet that we could
talk about it's the pamphlet how deep
you want to know
we'll go about six inches
and uh
[Laughter]
um
no it's just it's a sad story there's a
lot of [ __ ] sad hollywood stories
were you still seeing her at the time
that was not you weren't no i i we had
been friends i had been friend because i
had woken up one day and i was just like
why am i dating a porn star
you know what i mean it doesn't really
make sense
you know like i'm you know
she's cool but then she's going to go
[ __ ] dudes on camera and i was like i
can't do that plus there's aids and [ __ ]
and all that other stuff and diseases
yeah so it's just like
it was just um
i just kind of woke up
you know
yeah so um yeah she she uh she uh was 23
that's young man to kill herself yeah
and she just had a lot of you know
things happening in her life you know
she was sick of being she was sick of
being a porn star she was sick of being
known as savannah
she had she had tax problems she owed
the money money the government she was
you know dancing it was just like
this you know she was in a it was like a
you know you get viral yeah it was like
a spiral thing so
she was uh
she was um
driving
with my friend jason
uh they got in a car crash kind and she
was able to kind of maneuver her car
back to her her house
and then he goes inside to get her like
a rag or something because she hit her
head and then when he comes back she
just
she did it in the garage
yeah so that was that yeah
so he saw he saw that then yeah jeez
[ __ ] yeah and that you know was [ __ ]
up because that's how i met him i met
him through danny boy from house of pain
um
i think i was buying my plymouth at a um
a car show um a pontiac um i got this
beautiful 69 road runner and um and i
met you know an unknown danny boy for a
while from house of pain and then um
jason i met and he's like yo i was with
savannah and blah blah
and you know it's just kind of like um
you hear i mean there's so many stories
so many i mean it just you know
but you were here for him that's the
thing there's so many you hear about but
you're right here in west hollywood
there's the suicide off the hotel next
to the store what was that comedian's
name yeah steve a bitken yeah
yeah is it really true he believed he
could hit the store
people say that i'm like man he had to
be [ __ ] up if he just even
logistically looked between the two
buildings he probably didn't get good
work you need a squirrel suit that
[ __ ] he probably didn't get good
spots you know
it's like [ __ ]
i'm not trying to make light of a
suicide i'm just making later the
distance between the two if that was
your point to hit oh i heard i i'm
you're going to be the person to ask for
this i've heard a story for years it's a
kinnison
uh it's one of those you know you don't
know if it's true or not
but the story i've heard for years was
your mom and kennison with butt heads
for a little bit and she would give him
the late night spot they called it the
kenneson spot he'd go like 150 to 2 or
some [ __ ] like that or whatever this is
what i'm hearing okay and the kennison
they had butted heads and she was like
you're never going to be huge or
whatever blah blah blah
again and then i don't know if they had
an argument or something but he took
some kind of a billboard out across from
the store oh yeah is there any truth to
any of this do you really remember this
i hear i don't know what it is him
giving a finger and then the city made
him take it down but again this you know
it's like telephone over 20 years you
know what's interesting is you bringing
that up actually i forgot about that is
that real yeah he did he did some sort
yeah he him and my mom yeah they butted
heads but even though they butted head
your mom still let him work there well
yeah it was that's what i'm saying yeah
he would get banned and then unbanned
okay i mean that's kind of what this is
yeah yeah we've all been banned you know
what i mean
so uh
that's just the way it that's just the
way it is so yeah he he did do he did
buy a billboard right across from the uh
from the or but i don't think he was
doing that i don't know what i gotta ask
that's a good question i want to know i
gotta ask his brother bill kennison
after we get off we could call bill all
right and then and then i'll tell him
that i just did your show so um but yeah
i do remember so there is true it may
not be the middle finger but there is
truth that he took a billboard sending a
message about something yes no [ __ ] yes
yeah
how about that
that's one i've heard for years and it
just remembered that i'm like i gotta
ask paulie that one
um all right so everything as you say it
doesn't last forever you're on this
trajectory you're going up what what
happens when because i remember
one of the best things i've i've seen is
the joan rivers documentary i don't know
if you're seeing that it's so good and
they talk about um
the her manager at the time
uh had also managed richard pryor and
he's like you know listen and richard in
year one we're gonna do this we're gonna
get your stand-up going year two maybe
work on a little special something three
and four we'll try to get you into some
movies and stuff like that and he said
richard pryor looked at him because
listen man that sounds great but what
the [ __ ] we gonna do about monday you
know what i mean like i don't have time
for this five-year [ __ ] and joan talked
about how
for years she had she had her it written
in a day planner and she just opens the
book and it's just white pages for years
and then boom
e hits and the oscars and she goes back
up so she talks about that you know
though
right
yeah yeah so what what is the beginning
of the first
hill down for you
and how are you handling that
um
i i think a lot of it had to do with the
fact that i didn't feel
joyful any i didn't feel that joyful
anymore what was the like i was going i
was going for well i was going from i
didn't know how to go from a a boy to a
man does that make sense it does yeah
because i i kind of went from a boy to a
man at 30.
okay
you know because i was a child-like guy
and then the weasel and all that [ __ ]
was very
you know to do you know what i mean it
was just i was i was burnt out i just
felt like more i had more um dimensions
in me than the ah
you know what i mean and you'd be so
within
12 years at the for that at that point
yeah so it was inside of me this this
kind of like relatable guy
i just didn't feel that
anymore
so you know i started to look different
i started to act different i started
becoming very i came very self-aware
that things weren't happening i i got
self aware that my box office wasn't
as good as it was
um i got self aware that the critics
were saying what they were saying and
you kind of start believing it because
the offers kind of dry up you're like
well maybe this [ __ ] movie was
terrible and maybe you know you start to
second-guess yourself
and so um
so i just took i'm a very very
vulnerable
like heart type of person like my mom
you know i make a lot of my decisions
based off of this and not this you know
what i mean which is exactly like my mom
my mom's heart you know
and um
and
i didn't look at it as a business you
know i took it personal and um
so what happened was is after my sitcom
got cancelled on fox
i decided that it was time for me to
kind of part ways with my agent and
manager i was with great agents and
great management but i was just like i
just needed a break
so then once i i i i you know broke up
with them
and then i kind of took a break and then
i went to my attorney jake
and i said um well now what now what do
we do
and he said you had a good run like just
chill like just chill like you had an
awesome run like no one does that
you know what i mean i'm so [ __ ]
stupid that i should have just said yeah
just [ __ ] chill dude like dude you
rocked like what i shouldn't have done
is fired them and just chilled and just
been like yo i'm just gonna chill you
know what i mean
and um
but i wanted to be alone because there
was stuff that i wanted to do and i also
knew that if i wanted to do certain
things they probably wouldn't let me
whatever it was anything you know i'm an
artist look at the internet now you
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah
and so i spit myself out you know to be
alone purposely kind of so i can connect
with people more because i felt like i
was up here and i wasn't here i wasn't
connecting so i kind of did that you
know i did that um
and it really you know it [ __ ] with me
you know i had lost you know i lost this
joy you know i lost this um
this fun the fun thing that who polly
sure
is you know joyful loving giving man
just someone who's crazy so i believed
in all that [ __ ] and i took it heavy
and then i um i hit bottom um
um
emotional emotionally what's that what's
going on i just i just felt um dead
you know i felt um
numb
you know i felt uh
you know um
i don't know i wasn't looking at life
half full
you know i was looking all this and it
was staying away from the store were you
withdrawing from everybody or just sort
of going through the momentum i was just
walking around with depression yeah you
know and um and then i uh called uh my
group therapy that i was involved with
when i was a kid called life spring and
um
and i called them up and they had a
another seminar and then i enrolled in
that you know kind of like aaa where you
you know for depression or sadness
so i enrolled into that and and i got my
joy back you know i was able to kind of
let go of all the you know the the the
chatter and let go of all the [ __ ] that
i created and just start over again
and then that's when i did paulie shaw's
dead you know and that's when i'm like
hey you know what i'm going to make fun
of that situation so not only
did he
he kind of go away but now he's going to
make fun of the fact that he went away
and to me pauly shore is dead is the
best movie i've ever done i mean i truly
believe it you know what i mean i mean
son-in-law and biodome are
bigger movies but if you watch paulie
shores dead you can see the pain in it
but you can also see the comedy in it
and um
and that paulie shore's dead to me was
the first part of the second part of my
career but because i put myself out
there i was able to learn to produce and
direct and act and edit and graphics and
mix and do like all this [ __ ]
like
i started doing this [ __ ] with polish
dead 20 years ago you know hd i shot hd
and you know blah blah blah and you know
and all that stuff and i hired my
cameraman brian to shoot it who shot my
totally polly show so i felt comfortable
with that guy and i directed it and i
got everyone showed up you know sean
penn's in it whoopi goldberg's in it ben
stillers in it eminem uh britney spears
dr dre you know everyone got the joke
and it was like awesome and it took me
five years did it took me five years but
to me it's the best thing i've ever done
because it's so [ __ ] honest but it's
so fake at the same time
because if you watch it like carrot top
moves into my house you know what i mean
but it's all played real real like
gritty and like docu-style and it's like
people are like [ __ ] i didn't know
carrot top moved in your house you know
and um
so
yeah so um
and then you know i started to kind of
like just
didn't take things so personal
you know i was just kind of like you
know does someone talk [ __ ] like okay
great you know what i mean like they
talk [ __ ]
and um
you know i just wasn't
i wasn't as a ever since then i was i
haven't been as affected
and ever since then it's been like this
you know what i mean and you know when i
do things and everyone listening that's
in the business just put your heart into
it
and and and and do the best you can and
and say goodbye to it and and leave it
you know and then it's like a [ __ ] you
flush go yeah exactly it's like it's
like uh pinocchio this this you know
coming out in the voice of pinocchio i
did it and i moved on and then it went
viral you know my voice and everyone's
like oh pinocchio i'm like all right
you know what i mean and lionsgate's all
happy and i'm like that's awesome
you know and if it didn't that'd be
awesome too
you know and um
that's what this business is it's not
about anything else but just putting
your heart into it that's what life is
yeah
doing it because this is my life and
give it your best yeah this business is
my life this is why i continue to do it
you know what would you do if you didn't
have high interest loans or credit card
debt would you move to a new city would
you start a family through upstart you
can pay off your existing debt quickly
with a personal loan so you can tackle
your next big financial goals whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
just five minutes for loans between a
thousand all the way up to fifty
thousand dollars and you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
honeydew whatever way you challenge
yourself there's no better way to do it
than with a pair of raycom wireless
earbuds in your ears raycom wireless
earbuds are the best way to bring audio
with you because no matter how much you
shake things up literally no matter how
much you shake you know they won't fall
out of your ears their everyday earbuds
look feel and sound better than ever
there's also awareness mode for when you
need to listen to your surroundings so
you can take raycons with you wherever
you go with optimized gel tips for the
perfect in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me flying with them
exercising with them cleaning around the
house with them wearing them outside
here at the studio i'm telling you they
don't fall out raycon's off for eight
hours of play time and a 32 hour battery
life and they're priced just right you
get quality audio at half the price of
other premium audio brands it's no
wonder raycon's everyday earbuds have
over 48 000 five-star reviews and listen
you know how long raycon's been
sponsoring this show if you're not
getting them they're not coming back so
clearly people are buying them and
clearly they're very happy with raycon's
right now honeydew listeners can get 15
percent off their raycon order at
buyracon.com honeydew that's by
raycon.com
honeydew to save 15
on raycons by raycon.com
honeydew it's a hectic time of the year
between weddings graduations spring
sports and more we're busier than ever
right now and sometimes we forget to
take a second for ourselves so this
season take a second to enjoy an ice
cold coors light because you deserve a
beer that's made to chill and anytime i
want to chill with a beer it's coors
like doesn't matter if i'm at the club
doesn't matter if i'm at the cookout if
i want to chill and relax with an ice
cold beer it's coors light the mountains
on the bottles and cans they even turn
blue when your beer is cold that way you
always know when it's time to chill
coors light is cold lagered cold
filtered and cold packaged it's as crisp
and refreshing as the colorado rockies
perfect for a moment to unwind so
remember to take some time for yourself
this season you're out there doing a lot
all right have a nice ice cold coors
light for yourself when i need to take a
second for myself i'm telling you i'll
reach for the beer that's made to chill
get coors light delivered straight to
your door with drizzly or instacart by
going to coorslight.com
honeydew coors brewing company gold in
colorado celebrate responsibly now let's
get back to the do so yeah it's been um
it's been interesting but i definitely
look at my life half full
you know i mean you know
i have to you know three four decades
into this business first of all again i
you're alive yeah this business takes a
lot of people young quick you've known
some
you're still here and you're thriving
yeah you know
my penis is thriving
i saw it the other night at the store
[Music]
um all right so then after paulie shore
is dead
do you see
uh uh is that a start of another back up
to the top again more of an incline i
was not looking at the
i was not looking at
the box office i wasn't looking at the
money i was looking at what was going on
here and this was happening
you know i was doing movies after
creating [ __ ] from scratch
like i can make [ __ ] from scratch i can
go into any town in this [ __ ] america
and enroll a director a writer a camera
guy an editor a graphics and make [ __ ]
from scratch yeah like i moved to vegas
and the crew that i got out there's
never done comedy before
you know one guy you know does football
the other guy does dj stuff you know
what i mean but i've got them
so
i'm i'm i like to make stuff from
scratch because it's [ __ ] hard you
know um so i did uh after that i did uh
what was it natural born comics i think
with charlie murphy and t-pain did the
ari shafir's in it ian edwards is in it
we did that in um in in miami then we
did [ __ ] what else do we do adopted
where i go to [ __ ] africa to adopt a
black baby which i [ __ ] shot in south
africa which was [ __ ] gnarly we did
that that was that was [ __ ] [ __ ]
funny dude
and i just make stuff so i've done tons
of stuff since then
and then um and then guest house came
out two years ago and that did really
well for me too so that was a starring
role in a film
um so and i have this other movie that i
wrote called
uh
stuck in the hood which is me with a
bunch of black people
and i think that i think that's a good
it's a good time for just to do
something like that now
you know
yeah so uh
you know but i do pee a lot
you gotta pee not right now but
i thought that was like a queue no
but yeah so
i don't know you know i'm lucky you know
so you are lucky yeah yeah
so
talk to me about some of the close
people in this business that you you've
lost like who you mentioned um gary
garfing yeah gary garfinkel yeah he was
you guys were really close yeah gary
garfinkel was one of my big supporters
when hollywood wasn't supporting me
you know um
about those people yeah your real
friends yeah so basically gary and i
became friends years ago probably over
20 years ago he ran the commie
department at showtime so he produced a
lot of comedy specials like when
showtime was spitting out a lot of
special that was his department
so we became very friendly we'd go the
playboy mansion together i got to burp
one sec
we would go to the playboy mansion
together and um go to nice dinners at
dantana's and just laugh he was just
silly
and um and became friends with a lot of
his friends he became friends with a lot
of my friends and he let me stay at his
house a lot like if i wanted to come
over he lived up the street from my mom
so we would just hang out you know and
he was just a really sweet guy
and then
um
one afternoon i'm in san diego i think
i'm with sandy danto's opening for me
and i think i'm in the parking lot of
[ __ ] like roberto's or some [ __ ] and
then he gives me gary gives me a call
and he's like dude i have something to
tell you you know he he had like the
stroke thing you know like a stroke he
goes oh it's nothing you know it's kind
of in denial of it and uh
and i'm like and i started crying i was
like dude what you know what be like you
like all of a sudden getting a call that
you got like a lump you're like what the
[ __ ] is this and then he got the um he
got the mri and then he had like this
brain cancer tumor thing
yeah so then you know
close friend um and this happened uh uh
you know and then he died it was [ __ ]
and it was [ __ ] up and this was f he
was 54.
yeah and he was like a good guy and
[ __ ] beloved in the business and and
all the comics of them you know jeff
ross knew him everyone knew gary
garfinkel and and he was just a
sweetheart and um and now you're 54 do
you think about things like that yeah i
[ __ ] yeah
yeah are you taking care of your health
like do you go to the doctor i don't
mean yes drink pressed juices and [ __ ]
are you good absolutely yes i actually
have to have some sort of piss what's it
called a piss uh
piss um
thing to sample no because i pee a lot
oh yeah i don't have an enlarged
prostate it's weird but my my prostate
goes like you know i mean
it's just it what's happens when you're
50. yeah you know i start peeing a lot
so i just uh i got to go get that
handled and but other than that you know
after i found out gary died of a brain
brain tumor and cancer and all that
stuff i wouldn't have my brain checked
yeah and they didn't find anything in
there and that's empty
it's just an empty nest it was like the
tin man hello hello hello are you in
there are you in there are you in there
um
but uh um yeah i had that checked and
you know thank god because you don't
[ __ ] know
you know i mean we all we all don't make
it to 80. yeah i mean it's like you know
i was like my dad made it to 92.
92. so comedy that's like 192.
yeah so it really is that was my dad was
funny
i would be like dad let's go outside
he's like for what just leave me the
[ __ ] alone i've seen everything don't
[ __ ] touch my body
i'm seeing everything i'm good i'm good
right
um and my mom she lived to 87 and my
sister she passed that what was it uh um
i think 63 and she didn't take care of
herself you know
she she wasn't healthy
so um
yeah man
you know and then we all went through
this this covet thing which was really
um i thought you know
i thought it was [ __ ] but i also thought
it was really good in a way you know
because now when we walk around
we look at things like this more
you know all these shoes yeah and um so
yeah
yeah it's made me look a comedy like
that too like
if if i'm gonna leave my kids and get
get on a plane and go to a city and work
a weekend it's gotta be worth it
it's gotta be worth it and if it's not
i'm not gonna [ __ ] do it you know
what i mean i don't know how many more
summers i have left
i'm 49 i am an ending comedy and been in
comedy so how long have you been in it
for
um since nine i mean 22 years now i
started at the comedy store the first
times i ever performed was uh your belly
room after the first you know uh open
mic belly room in 99
was fall staff in charge
do you remember him no you don't
remember falstaff no
i don't remember he was the best really
he was this big big gay guy with like a
sailor hat and he would like host a show
and like
you know he was he's just this big gay
dude and i think he like adam barnhart
ran the show that's his net was his yeah
forever yeah that was the one that i
performed on in the belly room on like i
don't remember that's when fortune
worked on that right fortune feamster i
think she said that i think so
yeah that was a stateful bro yeah fall
staff was [ __ ] hilarious
but um
yeah so um
yeah it was all like for me it all
happened kind of in a year or two like
my mom my dad my sister gary that whole
time oh that was all that's part of the
reason why i moved to vegas you know
um because i just wanted to get out of
la i wanted to get away and then the
pandemic obviously that had a lot to do
with it so is moving to vegas the first
time you've lived anywhere other than
los angeles wow
never
anywhere else
and what's it like to leave home
for you
do you like it do you like being in
vegas
yeah i mean you feel like you want to
get back no i'm going to come back
yeah i'll come back
you know you just it's just right now
yeah i'm back and forth right now um
it's just a better lifestyle in
california yeah vegas is [ __ ] dry
dude
you know it's dry during the [ __ ]
winter it's dry during the [ __ ]
summer it's freezing as [ __ ] during the
winter and it's hot as [ __ ] during the
summer
and
it's a little thrashed out there i mean
there's only like three really nice
places there's like
the strip there's henderson in
summerland and then everything else
looks like [ __ ] you know [ __ ] up
yeah it's [ __ ] up mangy dogs and
and uh it's a little thrash so that's a
little
you know
not fun for me and then also to be
honest there's not a lot of people in
the entertainment business out there
it's mostly singers and djs and bottle
service people and but there's not like
um
you know not a lot of editors and
production people not a lot yeah but
they just don't do that out there that's
not their thing
so i kind of need to be around
i need to be around you know people that
speak my language as you could tell i'm
an artist i got my pink awesome yeah i
mean i got my and my green glasses i
wore for you because i watch your show
and i know you like
you like green
this is called the wasabi this is called
the wasabi
[ __ ] bobby lee man this [ __ ] guy
keeps talking about my dick i'm gonna
punch him in his [ __ ] belly
[ __ ] ass curse them over their left
it's true dude he's got to stop talking
about it dude
stupid
him his brother stevie's funny huh
he's adorable yeah i want to get him on
here i think him and tony rock should go
on tour together i think i think all the
brothers of communities should [ __ ]
go on right and my brother scott can go
on tour right
um yeah that'd be [ __ ] the brothers
of
that's good
but yeah i um
i am the thing with you and in the uh
and the coughing has got to stop no i'm
just kidding no the thing yeah
he's still got coveted left over it's
the residue no but the thing just my
advice to you as far as touring
you know and i say this to myself too
you know what we can
yeah
meaning we can number one we got feet we
got hands we can carry our bags there's
a lot of people that can't
guess what's funny guess what's funny
dude like there's gonna be a time when
guess what we can't yes
so it's like if you could tour like
[ __ ] tour not a lot no i i go around
when i don't have my kids yeah i know a
lot but i just think it's it's you can
do it and then at the end of the day
it's really not about you it's about
them yeah you know what i mean so it's
like
that's why i go now yeah i'm selfish i'm
going out to i want to meet these people
that
comment and write all the positivity and
the love you know i want to go see them
live plus it's another skill set you
know
a lot of podcasters can't do an hour and
can't sell tickets i definitely can't do
an hour
but um it's funny because i was just
talking to my um accountants about they
were like hey want to talk to you about
like you know life insurance and all
that and then there's this disability
insurance they were talking about i go
well just explain that to me and they're
like well let's just say you're
some god forbid something happens and
you can't work
um this is a basically you pay monthly
on this for whatever amount of year i'm
like that's not for life they're like
nah and i'm like man i gotta roll a dice
on that because i go so i made them get
on the phone me i go here's how i feel
about insurance
if i'm in a wheelchair i could still
podcast as long as i have my brain and
my head if everything from here up works
i feel like an insurance company could
say you can still work right you know
what i mean because i could and people
do
there are people in wheelchairs that
that do stand up and [ __ ] like that
there are people that do that so how
could i argue that i can't you know
but i passed on that insurance help him
pray for me all
um
but you're right we can we're healthy
enough i go to the doctor twice a year i
don't go once everyone in my family has
died
so i'm on that [ __ ] i'm every single
what
well it was always heart disease
but i found out now this actually years
later that my father most likely instead
of a heart it was a heart attack he had
but it was a clot that killed him not
the actual like that
commercial
what's that one i haven't seen you know
where the where that gets clogged in the
drain and they pour the 80 do and then
it deposits
it remember yeah
[Music]
yeah that's okay the draino [ __ ] it was
clogged yes
declogged that [ __ ] yeah
so years later and and he was 42 and
this was 89 so the doctors now say look
man if you died that young back then
most people just ruled it a heart attack
and we're learning more and more these
days that most likely a lot of those
could have been clots and things like
that that weren't uh just a heart attack
so i'm in there i i know i have a blood
disease which is i'm prone to clotting
called factor five lighting so i'm
always making sure you're gonna be
giving it to me jesus christ
give me a blood disease
so i'm on that [ __ ] dude i'm on it
i got ear [ __ ]
twice a year what do you mean ear i have
a uh superior something bub about
dysfunction where i have a um
my ears are always full does it [ __ ]
with your balance and stuff no no
but you're hearing my hearing's perfect
so you just have to get them drained no
there's just like a claw it's like a sl
a small like
clog and how do you get it out i don't
well so eventually we'll be deaf
no
that just it's just it's an ear disease
i'm gonna give it to you you give me
your blood disease and i'll give you my
[ __ ] ear disease and we can mix that
[ __ ] up let's do it right yo bro baby
wees chinese face
right
where is that guy
if bobby lee was here we would tie him
up bro bobby lou tie him up and smack
him
yeah i would love to smack bobby lee
around a little bit i think he'd like it
though you know that's true he'd
definitely be into it
all right talk to me about i want to
talk to you about your mind
yeah yeah we can pause it right here you
can go pee
i'd love to talk about your mom because
i uh i'm officially passed at the comedy
store now which is an honor and yeah she
told me
he's gonna get your sticker he's so
funny mom mom there's no room for him on
the [ __ ] wall you figure it out
figure it out
uh but no emily laford um
which i love that i love first of all i
love emily laford who also books this
show
and she's the one that that put me in
the system and you know i had to do the
work and she passed me so i love the
fact she and i go back forever i love
the fact that after your mom it's her
for me okay and i love that a woman is
running the comedy store again
yeah she's trying to channel my mom yeah
but i mean there's not been a female
booker since your mom right i don't
think so right yeah yeah so it's back in
a in a lady's hands it's interesting and
i see her work in the
the um sets i mean i i don't always go
in the same spot you know i see her
making me go last or next to last early
middle because that's all different you
know different crowds different rooms
and [ __ ]
oh she's got epilepsy though who emily
so she doesn't know where you're going
to go she's like [ __ ] it put them here
oh no i'm just kidding i was gonna say i
don't know about the check good on her
right now
talk to me about your mom and and the
whole legacy i mean
i want to say your mom is the king of
comedy you know what i mean
what person has put more people in front
of a microphone that have gone on to do
what these people have done she loved
her comedians but she also knew
brilliant comments yeah well she and
also i'm sorry to interrupt but
some people
like comedy and they dislike this one i
like clean comedy i only like this
comedy i like this comedy your mom
loved every range of it from i mean god
think about it rodri paul rodriguez and
carlin and pryor and kennison and and
dice and all these guys are so [ __ ]
different
tsuki
tamatsuki
so talk to me about it
like you're seeing every kind of comedy
growing up
and your mom i know she loved them but
she also had that eye
yeah well that's i mean it was it was it
started with my father you know she
would give him pointers
and then she got the store and then she
started giving other comedians points
did she ever do comedy does she ever
perform never not even younger on camera
no what got her into comedy my father
really yeah just seeing him perform as
well they met at a place called elkhart
lake wisconsin so my dad was performing
there my dad was the original okay yeah
you know that right yes like the
original original dude like he was on
tour
you know like we're on tour he was on
tour in the 50s playing [ __ ] you know
strip clubs bars
camps wherever he could get stage time
so he was just there he came up he came
across a gig
called elk in elkhart lake wisconsin
which was a camp
um and my mom worked for the boss at the
camp and then my mom would watch my
father and she would type up his jokes
just on her own yeah but they were
[ __ ]
right but she's not telling him he's
she's doing this or is she
yeah oh they started working together
yeah sure hey do this sammy try this one
this was good
that's not funny try you know she would
just kind of like you know
help him out you know i mean and support
him
and you know and he was very nervous
around her because he kind of knew that
she was right
you know and that was her natural
instinct to help and and guide you know
him
so then when she got to the store and
they they started that it kind of and he
was off in vegas you know working with
elvis and and touring and doing his
whole thing she naturally kind of took
over the store because she you know and
then the boom hit
so it was also the right place at the
right time right club
you know but it was his club and then
she she ran it after that right um but
um she was just you know again
i i've said this before it's kind of
like justin bieber on the steps of in
toronto wherever he got discovered you
know he's just playing the guitar and
then usher sees them
right i mean that's kind of how that
happened so
you know she was at the store and
letterman showed up and robin showed up
and and all these different guys showed
up and it was her club and she would she
loved her comics and she just
was more into them than her kids
you know and um
yeah she just enjoyed it you know it was
a natural thing to her and i think
that's
one of the reasons why i think she got
sick is because of the business part of
it
you know what i mean was was she didn't
like that part of it
um because she wanted to be an artist
and helping you know helping comedians
so
you know it's hard to be both yeah who
were your favorites to see live when you
were a kid like you're you're floating
in and out of there what from four to
now
who who who was like well eddie murphy
was pretty much one of the best you got
to see him
[Music]
he's about to go on tour he's got to
come back in there they said he had a
tour book before the pandemic and he's
doing [ __ ] for netflix i hope he comes
through yeah
so um
so him and then obviously um
you know cheech and chong george carlin
i saw i saw the whole i saw the whole
george carlin run at the end before he
passed
he was working out there a lot you know
in the main room
and it was pretty cool because he was
like a scientist
you know he wasn't even that funny it
was like [ __ ] brilliant but then
you'd laugh you'd be kind of watching
like you know he i think he had more
comedy specials than any comic i think
he had 14 hbo special is that right yes
i know he was he was considered the most
prolific writer in our art form and he
released a special maybe every three
years now they're turning it
so quick i feel like that's what has
watered down
uh a lot of the stand up i see these
days well there's just
there's not as many good comedians
that's all but i feel like some of the
comedy could be better if you worked on
it another year or two you know what i
mean like i'm really put that time in
and not just saying the same [ __ ] every
night but [ __ ] with the words here
and there like you say a scientist
moving this and around and changing the
uh the [ __ ] like that's a big deal you
know
um and then there was guys like lenny
schultz
who was uh one of my favorite comedians
and he was just insane do you know about
lenny's show
lenny schultz was um he was a pe coach
from ups uh catskills upstate new york
and he used to uh be insane he was
insane he was like
uh crazier than gallagher i remember
gallagher when i was a kid so as a kid i
liked that [ __ ] so he was like this
jewish guy he had a beautiful body and
he he he'd do all this weird she had a
lot of props but nuts it wasn't like
prop comedy it was just like this guy
was [ __ ] out of his mind
and um
he used to uh
you know juggle fish in the bowl he
would throw spaghetti in his face and
then he did this thing called the lenny
schultz diet and then after every show
he would um or
this would be his closer
so he would uh
he would basically um take off all his
clothes to his speedos and he would say
something like uh
a lot of people do diets and they put
the food in their mouth but on the lenny
schultz diet i put the food on the body
parts where you want to lose weight so
you put like chocolate pudding here
cottage cheese in his balls pour milk on
his head you know what i mean and people
were like what the [ __ ] and then i would
clean them up in the back you know where
we all hang out over there so i'd hose
them down and and clean them up um so he
was one of my favorites
and then there was dave tyree was
[ __ ] funny ollie joe prater was funny
uh uh jack perdue was funny um you know
you had jim carrey when he first came
out i was so so happy for him it was
such a spec it was interesting because
jim carrey
you know people don't people see people
just make it they don't see all this
[ __ ] before and before he made it he did
all these movies and in parts where he
just didn't work you know i remember he
did this movie called once bitten yeah i
remember remember that and it was just
like i don't want to say a vampire yeah
it was just like it just didn't work and
then i think his first one was ace
ventura yeah and that was the big one um
and uh
and i was so proud of him you know when
he came out and and he was kind of like
i don't say he surpassed robin williams
but at the time he was like the new
robin williams i mean he was getting 20
million a movie and he was
you know on a roll dude you know on a
roll like block but i mean these movies
were making 100 million a [ __ ] pop
yeah and that was like huge
so
he was great to watch and then for sure
dice was great to watch
i mean arsenio watching arsenio go from
[ __ ] you know from there to having he
had the hottest [ __ ] talk show no
doubt hottest talk show bill clinton
came on and played the saxophone
i was on his show a lot yeah on arsenio
it was really cool for me to do all
these talk shows like letterman and leno
because all these guys babysat me and
they watch me and i'm sitting across
some letterman i'm totally [ __ ] with
him you know if you look at old
letterman's with me it's really funny
really funny because he gets
uncomfortable because i'm like dude
you're on the comment store basketball
team stop [ __ ] with me you know [ __ ]
like that yeah it was great but he was
he was fantastic and that's why i
thought i thought binder did such a good
job on the on the dock
because um uh he was there
you know binder was physically there
so he he
he got the trust
from from all the comics
you know and um
and uh and you know annie did a good job
he's a good director so i was happy that
you know that he was the one that did
that
all right so you got pinocchio going on
now i got the one man show i'm i'll be
at the dynasty typewriter it's on my
website and i'm going to brooklyn i'm
doing some shows in brooklyn with it and
mike binder's directing it and then also
a company called radical media is
producing it so we're going to try to
sell it tell me more about though like
what are you doing it's cool what are
you diving into
just fun
in the womb yeah yeah give me a give me
a can you give me a story i talk i did
them all today
this is the fun stuff
i did them all today um i talk about my
dad opening for elvis i talk about my
mom partying with richard pryor and
robin williams i talked about my sister
dating filthy mcnasty but i mean when
you say you talk about your mom partying
with richard pryor roberts
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's scenes you know because
again i wouldn't do the [ __ ] show if
i didn't think it was interesting or i
want to hear all this [ __ ] yeah i
wouldn't do it if i didn't think people
thought that i thought that people would
think it was interesting
there's a lot of [ __ ] work that goes
into tell me something about richard
pryor because to me that's my all i mean
look i i say this all the time i think
richard's the greatest however
recently um i believe it was tom
segura's tour manager dave who told me
that eddie murphy had a tour
um of arenas before the pandemic hit now
i i don't question the validity of that
at all but if you haven't done stand-up
in decades and you're going immediately
into arenas i gotta say that there's no
question who
the goat would be
at that point
yeah i'm beyond crazy yeah but no
richard's the original i mean he's the
best you know yeah
i mean i i it's just his vulnerability
you know his likability what do you
remember about personal moments with him
he was just gentle was he a good guy
yeah
he was quiet yeah he was quiet yeah like
he would always kind of you know sit in
the back i would always go get him a
drink you know he'd come in you know and
i would shake his hand and follow me and
and then i'll go tell my mom richard's
here and then she'd go see him those are
those photos sometimes you see them
together
um uh
because you know i was the one that like
you know that was the owner's son
so you know i wanted to make sure
richard felt good he'd have a cigarette
and then you know and then i would
[ __ ] um
i would uh uh
the the mc would be like who's next and
then i'd like run up there and i'd
[ __ ] you know give him the piece of
paper right and then uh uh and then you
know the second say the word richard
pryor you know everyone [ __ ] it was
you know
it was like people
people just had a heart attack it was
crazy and then then he showed up and
you're like oh [ __ ] that's him
and then um towards the end of his life
he came up a lot you know in his
wheelchair which was cool and you know
um so you know got multiple sclerosis i
had him on my mtv show which was dope
you did get that one yeah i know that's
great yeah i [ __ ] sat down was right
before he started to kind of like yeah
sway you know so that was really cool um
and he laughed you know it was right at
the beginning of the wee's [ __ ] i
remember i was like he never lost his
mind i remember seeing an award um
ceremony where i can't remember who it
was they gave him an award and he could
no longer clap and his daughter took his
like sleeve and she just raised it up so
he could not wave and acknowledge the
crowd and stuff but then when he got out
there he's in his wheelchair they give
him this award and as they hand it to
him it falls a little bit and he sets it
in his lap and the first thing he says
is i'd like to thank y'all for giving me
this heavy ass award and i start late i
start laughing right away because it's
his body that's failing him it was never
at least at that point it was not his
mind it was still there his sense of
humor seemed to still be there and all
that [ __ ] you know
uh yeah it was uh you know he hit it
pretty hard you know he was he was you
know
he was rocking and rolling you know
so
well dude thank you very much for uh
coming on here and talking about this
stuff today
cool all good
promote everything again please oh yeah
so uh just on my social media just
paulie shore youtube polly shore my band
the krusty's um that's really fun i like
that that's [ __ ] stupid um and then
all the voice over stuff that's out and
then the one man show
is is everywhere i'll be in new york and
then i'll be here in l.a and before i
forget i'm gonna ask you because i
forgot to ask you before you plug there
uh advice you would give the 16 year old
polly sure now after the things we've
talked about today and
what would you say
well i would probably say you know
before you make certain decisions maybe
think more with your head
and not your heart
you know great advice yes you've got
your mom's heart yeah yeah and sometimes
you make uh
you know because you know because you
know the truth
you know you know the truth but
sometimes it's not about the truth
sometimes it's about
you know
some other [ __ ] yeah you know what i
mean so um
[Music]
you know
but it is what it is you know
like you said i'm alive
we're alive people watching we're alive
we've all been through
a crazy ass [ __ ] time [ __ ]
my hearts go out to all the people in
ukraine right now i'm watching that [ __ ]
yeah people are like what do you do at
night i'm like i watch the news and the
reason why i watch the news is because i
got a big heart
i don't watch the news to to you know
because my heart is hurting
for those people it's [ __ ] terrible
what's going on over there i've never
seen anything like that before
and guess what we're from there
those are our ancestors
my grandparents were from kiev is that
right
yeah
so you know those are all our people
you know and what he's doing there is
just [ __ ] just
it's it i it's it's you know i'm dying
so every night every night on videos
tanks coming down everybody imagine
like [ __ ] that's a city in the world
right now yeah yeah it's crazy yeah so
um
yeah i mean my hearts go out to to those
on
and uh and sean penn's out there right
now and making a
a documentary so
sean penn has done so much listen man we
all got vaccinations at dodger stadium
because of sean penn you know that right
no i don't that's all him man and he's
so when we were out um in line we're
getting our evan i are in the car we're
getting our first shot and he line you
up in dodger stadium
and
this lady's talking to us just worker
there and you know you're sitting in
your car and they'll you wait about 15
minutes they give you this you know boom
in the arm then they make you sit there
so no one
and sean penn just walking a lot little
tiny ass sean penn she's like he did
this because the the thing was the
vaccination at the time was available
but they were saying we don't know how
to get it to everybody and sean penn set
up this whole [ __ ] thing
i can't i'm gonna i can't remember the
name of his company and i want to it's a
core or c-o-r-e or something like that
but anyway he set it all up and we were
all able to go get these shots because
one dude gave a [ __ ] enough and was like
well let's just do this you know and
politicians aren't doing [ __ ] like that
yeah
yeah he's uh
i mean not only a great actor he's a
great dude he's done a lot yeah and um
he cares
he's got a big heart
you know and that's really what it's
about that's it is caring for people and
helping people yeah so i like helping
comics too
that makes me feel good it makes me feel
feel good to see you know josh martin
you know killing now uh you know jesus
sandy all of them
you know uh all these guys opened for me
for years
you know and before when they were open
for me i don't want to say they were
terrible
but they were pretty [ __ ] you know
what i mean
you put them out there in that audience
and they they've gotten good yeah you
know so yeah i like to help people
well thank you for doing this today bro
all right bro
thank you we'll see in the lot yeah i'll
see you tomorrow um ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you